this story you're watching this you're
kind of at first you're like oh this Joe
guy is an absolute scum back then like
oh my gosh Joe's a good guy
look at this Carroll Baskin wait a
minute this other guy this womanizer
who's got 28 wives this guy who believes
in polygamy look at so it's going back
and forth now I did some research and I
noticed you based on what I'm reading
you don't have three four or five six
wives these are just girlfriends of
yours or women that live on the campus
with you or some of them are employees
so what's the real story here now we
have this big family here there's 25 of
us that live here we live here because
we also have a hundred big cats that
we're working all the time big adult
lions and tigers so we make full contact
with all the time that requires people
to have real strong relationships with
those animals they have to be seeing
them every day the team has to get
together to take them in to bring them
out for wandering the forest with them
whatever it is we're working on and so
that team is a live-in team about half
that team are my relatives my son and my
daughter and my other daughter their
children my nieces nephews my mama lives
here a bunch of us are that family it
live here and run the facility other
people come on hey mom when they were
young have ate for decades because it's
an incredible lifestyle an incredible
opportunity he would be exposed to
wildlife in such a different way than
anywhere else in the world so from that
there have been a variety of ladies that
have come in they lived here they work
here and they take care of stuff and yes
I have been dating some of them for
decades and they all know about each
other of course we're all hanging out
here it's just not exactly what
everybody else thinks of as a normal
lifestyle but but you are a qualified
womanizer would you say that would you
say you're good with women I mean think
that that's smile I can see that smiles
work many times I don't I don't know
that that's a womanizer that gets a
little bit negative you know I hope I'm
a charming guy and with women but a
womanizer seems like maybe I'm treating
them wrong these girls live large their
lives are big and great they're super
talented earners their characters could
go out and work so hard they benefit
from it themselves her family
and live with them the girl Chyna who's
on the show she's there and she's got
her sister living with her they've
helped run things with me here for the
last 20 years they're super quality
ladies that just make the whole thing
rock so so I would assume I am 41 right
now okay I got an eight year old a six
year old and a three year old I got a
three year old daughter I am very
thankful for their not to have been
Instagram or snapchat when I was 18 19
20 years old because I just don't want
any of that stuff to be seen by my kids
because if they see some of the footage
they're gonna have to explain themselves
why that's a grandpa or anything like
that December that priority with the
wording and the language and a life you
live as you get older kind of like I
know I don't want to talk about it right
now I'm a grandpa I got kids I got
grandkids I don't need to bring that up
is that kind of would phase your aunt
sure to some extent certainly 20 years
ago on 60 when I was 40 years old life
was more Footloose and fancy-free
I traveled way more I lived on a lot of
big Hollywood sets I made a spin chiran
Jungle Book and Doctor Dolittle
I lived out Hollywood a lot of the time
I traveled around the world and did a
lot of different films and stuff so of
course you know you're in your 30s and
40s it's different life than you are in
your fifties and sick and you know
things are slower and faster according
to you know how engaged you really want
to be running amok and fabulous girls
who stayed on you know for decades and
they're so reliable and so good at their
job they are able to take care of my
other kids which are these big
chimpanzees and orangutans and elephants
and tigers and they make this ability of
those relationships which are very
extensive you know every single night we
have sit-down dinner with giant
chimpanzees they come in we cook dinner
with them they sit and that's why we're
the last ones in the Western world that
has these great big apes that come
interact with us it's a it's a bygone
era that anybody even knows how to do
that any longer would you prefer animals
or human beings people are phenomenal we
have emotion and we have capacity
to be incredibly cool most people are
lost in their sauce and are living on
social media they don't know which ways
up so those guys I'd rather hang out
with an elephant or a monkey but if
you're really living to your ability
well you have this incredible insight
into the creation and all the things
that are so great about it there's
nothing like great human art to inspire
but I love a chimpanzee to come down and
eat an orange with him and let just how
much he likes his orange is pretty
amazing
that's gotta be cool now
[Music]